Let's go straight into the questions
regarding the preparation. What did
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam do in order
to welcome Ramadan? What was his
preparation for Ramadan?
>> There's a hadith which is mentioned in
Sai Bkari number three book of fasting
hadith number 1969. The wife of the
prophet Hazat Aisha may Allah be pleased
with her. She says that the prophet he
never fasted any month completely except
the month of Ramadan and in no month did
he fast as many days as he fasted in the
month of Shabban. So from this hadith we
come to know that prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in order to
welcome the month of Ramadan he used to
start he used to prepare himself and
fast more in the previous month that is
the month of Shabban. That was his way
how he used to prepare for the month of
Ramadan. And further if you read the Sai
had inmedi
chapter number 15 had number 3451 which
says that tala may Allah be pleased with
him. He said on the authority of his
father that his father that is his
grandfather he said whenever the prophet
saw the new moon used to always pray to
Allah subhana wa t'ala and say oh Allah
bless us in this month and he used to
mention the name of that month and then
say that please keep us steadfast in
faith in this month. This was the way
the prophet always used to pray to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala whenever he saw a
new moon. It wasn't specifically only
for the new month of the month of
Ramadan but it was for all new moons
whenever we used to see and his special
way of welcoming the month of Ramadan
was that he used to mention about the
coming of this blessed month to the
people
and it's mentioned in Musnat Ahmed
number two page number 230 had number
where prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
used to tell the people that Oh people,
this blessed month is approaching you
and Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month and the gates of heaven will be
open in this month and the gates of hell
will be closed and the devils will be
chained
and in this month there is a night which
is better than a thousand months
And if anyone is deprived of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala's blessing in this
month, he's truly a deprived person. So
here we come to know that this is how
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam used
to welcome this month and he used to
tell the good news of the blessed month
to come to all the people.
>> Mashallah.
>> The next question to you is what should
we do when Ramadan approaches? The first
thing we should do is we should thank
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala for making us
witness this blessed month of Ramadan
once again. And we have to thank him for
his mercy. And we have to ask
forgiveness in this month so that all
our previous sins will be forgiven.
And we have to thank him for all the
nyamat he has given us, all the
blessings, all the love. This is the
best month. And Allah subhana wa tala
says in the Quran in surah bakar chapter
number two verse number 185 it says
which means that Ramadan is the month in
which the Quran was revealed as a
guidance for mankind
and signs
for guidance and judgment between right
and wrong. And Allah further says in the
Quran in surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 183 Allah says
oh you who believe
oh you who believe fasting was
prescribed to you as it was prescribed
to people who came before you. So that
you may learn
self-restraint.
The word used here is
similar to tawa. So that you learn god
consciousness. So that you learn pity.
So that you learn righteousness. So this
is the month in which a person can
become more righteous. This is the time
when a tawa can be the highest. And this
is a month. It is an annual training. It
is a sort of an [snorts] overhauling of
the body. How we have that every
machinery requires some sort of
servicing maybe every 3 months, maybe
every year. And if you allow me to call
the human beings as the best machinery
in the world, doesn't it require a
servicing or overhauling? So Ramadan is
an annual overhauling of the human body.
It is a spiritual and moral training for
the human being and it is a purification
of the body, mind and soul. This is the
month where we can increase our tawa. We
can increase our patience and we can
derive the benefits and the guidance
from the Quran.